hello
all you capitalists you socialists you
anarchists you communists
and other assorted people uh this is the
reuben report direct message for october
2020 one week from today
the fate of all our lives will be
decided
the fate of the economy the fate the
fate of the environment
the fate of whether you will ever be
laid again will all be answered
depending on whether joe biden or donald
trump
become or remain the president of the
united states
it's going to be a wacky week and we've
got a lot to get to
so we're going to be mixing it up today
some funny stuff some silly stuff some
election stuff
and some serious stuff i should tell you
before i do anything else though
uh that's starting today if you guys
want to jump over to the blaze tv
they got a crazy deal it's 30 bucks off
an annual subscription
so that you can get it for the cool
cheap discounted price so 575 a month
the discount ends on election day
november 3rd so check that out okay so
let's get to a whole bunch of stuff
because there's a lot to talk about oh
and i just did interview
alan dershowitz the harvard law
professor legal
scholar one of the last remaining 10
sane liberals on the planet i did
interview him this morning
all about the amy coney barrett
confirmation which i'm going to talk
about
in a few minutes myself but we went into
some of the
the legal specifics the sort of hysteria
the media reaction and all that it's a
mini interview it's about 20 minutes
we're going to be posting that
this afternoon and then i'm going to do
an extended interview with alan
dershowitz
uh after the election so that will be up
on the youtube channel a little bit
later
uh all right we've got a couple stories
for you i want to start with one i'm
going to make it very very quick
because uh it's fairly obvious and
self-explanatory
some of you have may may have seen this
already this clip that was going viral
over the last couple of days this is uh
chelsea handler who i guess
is a comedian was a comedian is is
basically just
sort of like a hysteric nutty lefty
whatever she is um but she was
explaining
to uh to jimmy fallon why 50 cent
50 cent i'm a big fan of the 50. uh why
he shouldn't vote for trump because he
said that he was going to vote for trump
and let's throw to the videotape you
heard about my ex-boyfriend right 50
cent and his support
of of uh donald trump yeah what's going
on between you i i saw your tweets and i
go wait what's happening because
you said he was your favorite
ex-boyfriend and then he
what is he supporting trump he says he
doesn't want to pay 62 percent of taxes
which by the way isn't a plan of
joe biden's that's that's that's a lie
so he doesn't want to pay 62 percent of
taxes because he doesn't want to go from
being
50 to 20 and i
and i had to remind him that he was a
black person
so he can't vote for donald trump and
that he shouldn't be influencing
an entire swath of people who may listen
to him
because he's worried about his own
personal pocketbook so
i haven't heard back from him yet but i
i am willing to
you know seal the deal in more ways than
one if he changes his mind and publicly
denounces donald trump i might be
willing to go for another spin
well as i said i want to make this one
kind of quick
and to that point chelsea handler if
you're watching
you're a racist yeah that's what we call
old-fashioned racism
you see a black person who doesn't think
the way you want them to think
and you get to although i get it you're
being kind of glib and jokey but in
effect you get to take away
their blackness i had to remind him
that he was a black person so he can't
vote for donald trump
uh this is the same donald trump who at
his state of the union back in january
was talking about all-time low black
unemployment and the congressional black
caucus and all the dems sat there like
this and didn't applaud
you know i'm old school i thought that
low black unemployment i thought that
would be something we could all get on
board it's sort of like middle east
peace i thought that was one of the
things that we always wanted
but apparently not but this this is what
we call the soft bigotry of low
expectations
and if you think that black people
aren't allowed to think for themselves
if you think that
that people like the brilliant thomas
soule
or larry elder or david webb or candace
owens or
tim scott or the litany of other black
people who aren't
just default democrats by the basis of
their skin color you think they're wrong
or they're somehow less black or they're
sellouts or uncle toms or the rest of it
you in fact are the racist this is a
more pernicious racism
than say oh i don't want those people
using those water fountains which
obviously is racist and everyone is
against that that that type of racism
in essence doesn't exist anymore it's
it's gone there's nobody
remotely close to anything mainstream
that wants different laws for black
people or latino people
or gay people even or anything else
we've obliterated that sort of bigotry
and what we've been left with is is
lefty
bigotry that they think they own you as
a person so if you're a black person
and you're watching this guess what dave
old dave here
he thinks you're allowed to think
whatever you want and if you're a white
person you can think whatever you want
and a gay person and a straight person
and a christian and a jew and a muslim
you are entitled to think whatever you
want and hopefully you've thought about
it for yourself and come to a conclusion
and
and the things that make you you whether
it is your skin color or your gender
your sexuality
they do not define you except without
that the left pretty much has nothing
and i think they're in for a rude
awakening next week
uh i predicted about a year ago that
trump was going to get about 30
of the black vote and i got a ton of
hate from
from tolerant lefties on on twitter
saying i was crazy and blah blah blah
i don't know that it's going to be 30
but i i think it is going to be
it is going to be shockingly a lot uh we
know that the brexit movement that
candace is doing we know about
black voices for trump and a whole bunch
of stuff and just there's a tectonic
shift
and if you're thinking that the polls
are telling you what's going on i think
you got another thing coming
all right that's all i got on chelsea
you're an old-fashioned racist chelsea
sorry
i hate to tell you uh let's talk about
mack weldon for a sec michael help me
out here i want to talk about mack
weldon
uh they are the sponsor of this week's
show and i seriously love mack weldon i
i wear
i've got i've got sweatpants i got
hoodies i got
uh you know knit tops and t-shirts and
the whole thing there are premium men's
essential
brand that believes in smart designs and
high quality fabrics mac weldon offers a
one-stop shop for men's basics they got
socks shirts hoodies underwear
polos and active shorts whatever you
need mac weldon has you covered
unlike the assortment of department
store brands that make up your top
drawer all
of mac weldon's basics have a consistent
fit that you can count on
mac weldon offers a wide range of
customized fabrics that can
keep up with you no matter what your day
looks like such as the 18 hour jersey
silver air knit x dry knit warm knit
even cashmere and i'm telling you guys i
love the sweatpants it finally cooled
off
in uh in la the last couple of days and
i'm wearing sweatpants at night and who
doesn't love
a good pair of sweatpants mac weldon has
created a totally free loyalty program
level one gets you free shipping for
life once you leave reach level two by
spending 200 bucks mac welding gives you
off every order for the next year mack
weldon wants you to be comfortable so if
you don't like your first
pair of underwear you can keep them and
they'll still refund you no questions
asked
and for 20 off your first order visit
macweldon.com
ruben and enter promo code ruben that's
20 off your first order when you visit
mackweldon.com
ruben and enter promo code ruben i think
you got the point again for 20
off your first order visit macweldon.com
reuben and enter promo code ruben
and now back to the show hello i'm dave
okay
let's move on so i wanted to talk a
little bit
about the amy coney barrett hearings as
i mentioned i did this interview with
alan dershowitz
a harvard law professor and legal
scholar who's been
in this fight forever and you know he's
he's on that short list to saint libs
he's he's still
you know planting that flag and he
doesn't get invited to dinners anymore i
know a little something about that
uh but we'll be posting that a little
later this afternoon but i wanted to
uh show a clip of of acb
as we're calling her we went from rgb to
acb
uh i want to show a clip of her and then
i want to show a couple tweets
by by some of the mainstream democrats
on how they're reacting
to this thing now before i even set up
the clip i just want to say the
the thing that was the obvious piece
that the media really was struggling to
deal with the entire time as they were
as they were making hay
out of this whole thing which is that
she was going to be confirmed without
question i did videos saying that weeks
ago the second trump nominated her
everyone knew that she wasn't going to
be kavanaugh
right they weren't going to be like oh
we found 20 guys who say you sexually
harassed them 30 years ago
and everything else she's got seven kids
several adopted kids by every measure
this is a good decent woman some people
aren't happy
about her faith which actually is
bigotry um
and they you know people were upset that
she's she's adopted two kids from haiti
as if that's what somehow white
supremacy is when you take
kids and you and you treat them as your
own i mean these people are just
completely bananas but the but the
simple truth of the situation
is that she was going to be confirmed no
matter what
sadly the way our system works now is
everything is done on partisan lines
and the republicans had the numbers not
only did they have the numbers but even
if one or two people defected
they still had the vice president mike
pence as the
as the tiebreaker so we all knew it was
gonna happen and it was all theater
and remained and continued to be theater
into yesterday so let's let's throw to
this clip this is
acb uh after she was confirmed and then
we'll throw to some of these democratic
uh tweets these genius tweets let's go
to the clip
one of the fundamental differences
between the federal judiciary
and the united states senate
and perhaps the most acute is the role
of policy preferences
it is the job of a senator to pursue her
policy preferences
in fact it would be a dereliction of
duty
for her to put policy goals aside
by contrast it is the job of a judge
to resist her policy preferences
it would be a dereliction of duty for
her to give in to them
federal judges don't stand for election
thus they have no basis for claiming
that their preferences reflect those of
the people
this separation of duty from political
preference
is what makes the judiciary distinct
among the three branches of government
all right so it's obvious to anyone
watching that that this woman is well
qualified for the position
and is going to judge as fairly as
possible we understand her judicial
philosophy
you may not like her philosophy but that
in and of itself doesn't exclude her
just because you don't like her judicial
philosophy
you may remember a couple weeks ago even
john king on cnn
said that in normal times a woman with
her track record or a nominee i don't
even
think he said woman a nominee with her
track record would have gotten 70 votes
i actually asked dershowitz about that
this morning i said if if we didn't live
in such crazy partisan times
um is there anything about her record
that
that would have left this in a weird
situation you know this sort of
completely partisan 51 49 situation
and basically he said in in normal times
uh she would have got 98 votes meaning
that virtually everyone would have voted
on her because you don't vote
for people that you think will will make
judicial decisions exactly as you wish
them to be
you're voting on whether you think
they're qualified to do the job
and by the way you know i see a lot of
people that are sort of hysterical
around oh now the court is going to
swing more conservative
there are times when it swings more
liberal but it certainly will be more
conservative
it will look at the world through a more
conservative judicial lens there's
there's simply no doubt
about that um and i see a lot of people
worried about that but you also have to
remember that the judges once they're in
there they don't always
rule on things exactly as you think they
are going to there are many many
instances of this
so i mean just john roberts and
obamacare right they they didn't think
he was appointed
by a republican people didn't think that
he was going to be for obamacare in
essence he was
there's a lot there's a lot of evidence
of that but i do want to address
uh two specific things that a lot of
people my more
liberal friends and family and and
viewers are asking me about
uh before i get to the to the democratic
tweets on this the two issues that seem
to be
coming up and i have a lot of genderless
anime trolls on twitter
saying now the court's going to take
away your marriage dave the implication
being that this conservative court
is now going to take away gay marriage
which as you know couple years back
the supreme court decided under the
equal protection clause that's what
justice stevens wrote about that that
gay marriage was the law of the land
that we should have equality for all
people
now this is what the court has always
done it has always expanded equality for
more people right
it doesn't give people special rights it
gives people equality
that's what that judgment did and i
think it's a sound
judgment and and most people from what i
understand think that it's a pretty
sound judgment there are there are
people that lean on the more
conservative side of it that still
would have preferred it had been left to
the states but i think justice stephen's
reasoning is sound and you can read the
you can read it for yourself does anyone
read the the justices decisions i'm not
so sure
but anyway you can but so a lot of
people are saying well dave they're now
you see what's going to happen
uh you right-wing maniac you right-wing
lunatic it's always lunatic or maniac
um that they're going to take away gay
marriage now
not only as i just said as the court
always expand writes it i don't know
that the court has ever
taken away rights taken away
equal rights from a group of people
that's just one thing but also
it isn't that the court just picks
things like oh we're a conservative
court we're just gonna
pick things to talk about we're gonna
pick things that we're going to make
judicial decisions on what happens is
court cases move up from local courts
and appellate courts
and district courts and all of those
things they move all the way up and this
process takes years and years and years
to get up to the supreme court
so the idea that a that this is going to
somehow happen tomorrow or something
like that like that's just crazy
but i know that's not in and of itself a
good enough argument i think the idea
that they won't take away rights is
but also the court moves at some level
the way the populace moves and they also
know that by reversing gay marriage
the endless litany of things the
pandora's box that they would open up
are you going to force all these people
to get divorced what are you going to do
with the kids
gazillions of legal questions and
financial questions
not not to put aside the human right
element of it and all of those things
so i just simply don't think it will
happen maybe years from now i'll have
egg on my face but i would be absolutely
shocked and i don't think it's something
that you should worry about the other
one
is the is the abortion one and here and
as you guys know and my
my more conservative uh viewers don't
love my opinion on this although most of
you have emailed me or many of you have
emailed me
to say that you'll agree to disagree uh
in my book i lay out the first trimester
case for abortion i don't deny that it's
life
uh but in a pluralistic society i think
you want the most amount of people to
have choice and
and let's not get into all of the
existential and philosophical and
religious issues
for this very moment but if you want to
hear some of my thoughts on that
you well you can either read the book or
listen to the audiobook or watch my
debates with this
with shapiro or prager or michael
shermer or a bunch of other people okay
um now there's that's not exactly what
roe v wade is right roe v
wade made abortion the law of the land
meaning it was federally
legal everywhere now personally you know
i'm a states rights guy
right i want as much to be done by the
states and as little to be done as the
federal government
so even though i am begrudgingly
pro-choice if
a case was to whittle its way and get
through the courts and i don't even know
that there's one in
in the court system right now but if a
case was to get all the way there to the
supreme court
um i don't know that personally i could
back roe v wade that isn't because i
want abortion to be illegal if they
reversed
roe v wade what that would do would kick
it back to the states and then
what i think you could do if you were if
you were a progressive if you were a
lefty if you were a good liberal and you
were upset by that because well then the
the local state legislators would have
to make it illegal so let's
let's say alabama then made abortion
illegal what you could do
and this is how you take control of your
life is if you really were an abortion
advocate and you wanted to make sure
that
people had access to abortions and
everything else you could start
nonprofits
you could start all sorts of fundraising
so that people
in whatever few states might reverse
the abortion ruling might make abortion
illegal
that they could get to the other states
and all expenses paid and they could
have the procedure and go home and you
could even give them bonus money
and all of the celebrities that are
constantly telling us how wonderful
abortion is like
bette midler and barbara streisand and
rosie o'donnell and the rest of them
put your money where your mouth is now i
know you don't like that idea you don't
you want it to be federal
but you know we happen to live in a
country with 350 million people and you
don't always get what you want
so i know that would be a little bit
messy but the power would go back to you
let's i think a lot of people think that
roe v wade suddenly if it was ever
flipped and by the way i'm not even
saying it would
be flipped and acb isn't even saying it
would be flipped
but if it got flipped it kicks it back
to the states it doesn't
make it illegal i think it's important
for people to have some understanding of
that but
okay let's move over to some of the
reaction
by the democrats and i've been warning
if you've been listening i've been
warning you guys that one of the things
that the left does is always
out banana itself it always out lefties
itself and there's nothing that's too
crazy for them
and i think if you see some of the
tweets by the democratic leadership
in response to acb who again is
supremely qualified to do this job
if you see some of these tweets as i'm
going to show them to you in just a
second
you'll see that they have much bigger
plans around this this isn't about
whether acb was confirmed or not this is
now how do we change the system
change or uh well change in the short
term but burn it down in the long term
so let's go to acb the jar jar banks of
politics i'm going to read her tweet
first
ac aoc says republicans do this because
they don't believe
dems have the stones to play hardball
like they do
and for a long time they've been correct
but do not let them bully the public
into thinking their bulldozing is norm
is a normal response oh wait sorry their
bulldozing is normal but a response
isn't
there is a legal process for expansion
so what she's saying in essence is
we did not get our way by the way when
they're telling you that the republicans
stole this or did something illegal or
or something like that
no the president is a four-year
president there's quotes from
ruth bader ginsburg rbg saying the exact
same thing
saying that the president he's voted for
four years if there's an opening he's
he's got to nominate somebody and that's
exactly what he did now are the
republicans hypocrites because they
stopped obama
from doing it uh last time knowing that
he wasn't going to get the votes
with merrick ireland yes they're
hypocrites you're not going to believe
it politicians are hypocrites
i cannot believe it and that goes across
the board isn't that crazy folks
politicians are hypocrites no doubt
about it but they did not do anything
illegal they used
power in last in the last case to stop
something when they had it in this case
to do something when they had it that's
what
power is and that's what politics is so
harry reid in 2013 when he did the
nuclear option
instead of a supermajority to confirm a
judge he said it has to be a simple
majority
well that was a very short-sighted term
so you can pin all of this
this 51-vote situation you can pin this
back on the democrats harry reid this is
all you man
and there's a tweet that you can find
where he's bragging about it and it's
and it's all you and i said it last week
but you can find a video
of me on the young turks as a lefty as a
progressive at the time
and i said this is going to bite you
guys in the ass the second you lose
power
they're going to use it in ways that you
don't want and that is the dangerous
thing about power that's exactly what
mitch mcconnell
said back then and that's exactly what
the republicans did right now
so there is a legal process for
expansion
expansion now that's changing the rules
now we're going to add judges
and if we have the power we're going to
add judges and by the way then the
republicans can get power again and then
they can add judges and remove judges
and it's just an endless nonsensical
game
so aoc doesn't doesn't want the she
doesn't like the system right she
doesn't like
capitalism she doesn't really like
democracy she doesn't like separation of
powers or any of those things
she wants it her way or the highway if i
don't get what i want with the processes
that are in place that we've always been
governed by we're going to just change
them that's what aoc is saying
let's go to kamala harris who is the
presumptive democratic nominee because
it
ain't and ain't old bag biden she said
today republicans denied the will of the
american people by confirming a supreme
court justice
through an illegitimate process okay
that's just not true it was a legitimate
process
all in their effort to gut the
affordable care act and strip health
care from millions with pre-existing
conditions
we won't forget this so everything she
said there is just complete nonsense
first off
it wasn't an illegitimate process
because if it was illegitimate meaning
illegal
they wouldn't have been able to do it
they did exactly what they are
allowed to do within the constitution of
the united states again you may not
like that but then you can also pass an
amendment but that would take
you'd have to be part of the system and
you'd have to pass things and do work
and that would be tough for these guys
so so harris is absolutely lying when
she says this is an illegitimate process
it is completely legitimate
um all in their effort to gut the
affordable care act now i don't know
it's all in their effort now
maybe they will gut some of the
affordable care act that
that is possible trump by the way
has repeatedly said and he said in the
in the debate the other night you don't
have to believe him i'm actually
not totally sure what i believe on this
that in his plan
once they gut obamacare enough although
biden's now calling it biden care
because you'll get the public option i
don't think obama's thrilled with that
oh yeah my signature achievement not
only trump's gonna
gut the whole thing i think you're gonna
switch the name to biden care i mean
it's it's also silly
um but this idea that they're going to
do the pre-existing conditions situation
because obamacare covered
people with pre-existing conditions and
that the idea of what she's saying here
is
they're going to try to screw over
people with pre-existing conditions well
trump
is saying that his plan will cover
pre-existing conditions
i tend to think that if that plan really
comes to fruition that they will because
it's
there's almost nobody that's against
that except maybe a health care
executive somewhere crunching the
numbers right an actuary who works
for for a health care uh firm or
something maybe that you know an
insurance firm maybe they're looking at
it
and going we don't want to cover it but
the public i'm pretty sure someone gave
me the numbers on this the public
regardless if you're a republican or a
democrat
people want people to be covered with
pre-existing conditions and by the way
not only do i completely agree with that
regardless of whether that was put in
place by a democrat or a republican if
the government's to have something to do
with health care
i think there's an interesting argument
there um
but not only do i see that as as
something that will happen either way
but but nobody's against it
that's the thing there's really you
can't find anybody that really
is against it so so harris's comment
here is just
patently disingenuous and then let's
throw to elizabeth warren
i'mma get me a beer elizabeth warren
she's such a human
isn't she such a native american human
uh here we go she says
hundreds of thousands of americans are
dead
and millions are waiting for the federal
government to fight this pandemic
republicans say sorry no time we have
better things to do than pass a relief
package
like steal a supreme court seat
oh liz liz liz liz
you left the range with that one um they
didn't steal the seat
i think i explained why the steel was
the seat was not stolen it was perfectly
legal and if it was illegal you'd be
doing something about it but you're not
because it wasn't illegal
and also the idea that they're doing
that instead of passing a relief bill
the republicans have a relief bill
sitting in the senate i recommend going
to dan
crenshaw's twitter feed to see what's
going on with that the the democrats
refused to pass it
and at this point i think there's
probably no way around it
they don't want it passed because they
want the american people to feel like
they're in pain right now so hopefully
they'll vote for biden that's just
that's just pretty obvious politics
again it dirty
it's dirty people uh so that's all about
that
if you want more of just sort of the
legal
ins and outs and some of the sort of the
blue sky stuff on that
as i said my interview with alan
dershowitz harvard law professor
we'll be up uh in a couple hours and uh
oh two
we got two stories i'm gonna do i'm
gonna do them somewhat quick over here
i'm man i'm windy today i am long-winded
uh first off
uh california this this clown state that
i live in
uh gavin newsom he was the former mayor
of san francisco ruined that city so now
he's ruining the entire state
i was in beverly hills yesterday there's
a big sign when you enter beverly hills
no trick-or-treating
stay safe stay home bananas
um well now they've issued a bunch
of well i can't say they're edicts
they're guidelines things that they
don't want you to do
for thanksgiving and before i quickly
read them here let's not forget
remember back in uh march it was 15 days
to slow the spread we're gonna
you know we're gonna flatten that curve
that was 15 days guys and then
everything will be back to normal
we're now like eight months later and uh
he's already making plans for a month
from now in thanksgiving
and these these plans are just
ridiculous quote
gatherings that occur outdoors are
significantly safer than indoor
gatherings
all gatherings must be held outside
attendees may go inside to use restrooms
as long as
restrooms are frequently sanitized i
want to be very clear about this i live
in california we host thanksgiving it's
the one holiday we host
uh i'm gonna do it however i want and
i'm gonna have as many people over
and you can send your stormtroopers to
my house gavin newsom
uh but it won't go well i still live in
a free country
and you don't get to tell me whether my
guests have to eat indoors or outdoors
um you're an awful human being um
then a couple of the new rules though uh
are really something here
all gatherings must include no more than
three households
because you wouldn't want four
households getting together because then
they start talking you know
that would be a problem masks must stay
on after eating and drinking and
singing and chanting and shouting or
strongly discouraged
what's thanksgiving if you can't shout
at your family
good god you authoritarian loons okay
final story speaking of authoritarian
loons the lincoln project you know these
people these are
a bunch of sort of um
i would say impotent republicans who got
everything wrong forever
and who back all the losing candidates
and everything else they've become these
never trump people
who are all supporting biden i don't
know what makes them conservatives by
any stretch of the imagination
uh if they're voting for a guy who
especially because of what he has coming
behind him is the complete antithesis
of everything they purport to believe
but they're extremely well
funded and they really like being liked
by the media and there's no way
to be liked by the media more than being
an anti-trump republican or a principled
conservative who always loses
right that's that'll get you a lot of tv
time on msnbc
and uh and the usual spots well they
released a video this morning
of uh well you you just watch i don't
want to color it for you take a look
hey honey
[Music]
you asked me to wake you and tell you
what happened in the election
who won
trump won
i thought you could only be president
two times
not anymore
[Applause]
the lincoln project is responsible for
the content of this
oh lord it's too early to drink i mean
these people are just
awful mommy is trump going to be
president
for a third term what are we going to do
and that
white privileged woman in her rich house
with her white
child and they ugh it's all just so
terrible yes it's not even about his
second term
it's about his third term but everything
that's wrong with everything is so
summed up
in this overly priced slick ad by a
bunch of people who never get everything
right and just keep sticking around
it's like yes that's what you're going
to do to your child that's child abuse
that's child abuse the night before the
election and it's going to be his third
term
i'll wake you up in the morning and tell
you if the president won and if not
we're going to pack the bags and run
obviously his whole second term went by
and they didn't do anything you guys
seem like you're doing pretty good
this is just lunacy they are playing on
your heartstrings
in the most dangerous sort of
gross it's actually gross what these
people are doing they're gross people
and and don't let them trick you into
doing
something that you don't want to do vote
your conscience whatever that is even if
it's completely against everything i've
said to you here
all right people i am off to santa
barbara i'm doing an event with richard
uh with bishop baron this evening and i
think that i don't think it's live
though i think we're going to hold it
and then they're going to
be posting in a couple weeks yes i got a
thumbs up on that one and uh
we're going to stop and get a little
chick-fil-a on the way that's the rumor
around the reuben report studio so maybe
there'll be a picture at rubidreport.com
of me eating
a hateful chicken sandwich you never
know anything's possible
all right one week left guys stay sane
more tomorrow
you